Speaker 1: Let's go next to Raoul
in Los Angeles, Raul. Go ahead.
Speaker 5: Hey, I'm just curious, I've got two
questions, I guess kind of a big, complicated
one and a bit more of an easy, specific
one. I'll let you choose, which do you want?
Speaker 1: Well, I'll take the easy one any day.
Speaker 5: How do you think the left
will maintain power during the midterm?
Speaker 1: It's not clear that they will. Yeah,
I mean, it's it's not looking good.
Speaker 5: That's kind of how I feel, I feel
like it's going to kind of be this constant cycle
of every two years, a general power structure
switches between either the president who was
just elected or who won during the midterm, and
it's just kind of a chaotic system, and I, as
a young person, feel kind of lost within it.
I'm more of a leftist, but in neither party
really speaks to me. You know, last candidate was
was Bernie, and now I'm just
kind of lost. You know what?
Speaker 1: What do you plan to do in November? Do
you even plan to? What's your what's your plan?
Speaker 5: I'll I'll vote Democrat. That's kind of
just what I've always done, I kind of tend to just
vote for who tends to my politics. Sure.
But I also kind of just prefer to focus
on the local stuff because that's where my vote
actually matters. A lot of young people think th